c'est un malheureusement cette réponse
sans annonce de date précise que je
pouvais m'attendre
c'est un manque criant de courage une
fois de plus que votre gouvernement que
je pouvais aussi m'attendre c'est à une
manipulation malhonnête que nous pouvons
nous attendre
car en effet même sans ratification du
sénat
l'accord reste en vigueur comme depuis
24 mois et pour une durée illimitée
c'est un exemple une fois de plus d'un
sénat bafoués que nous pouvons nous
attendre et encore plus que cela c'est
aux français que vous faites un énième
pied de nez c'est à des produits issus
d'une agriculture que les français ne
veulent pas chez nous que vous allez
continuer d'ouvrir les portes créant une
concurrence déloyale de nos produits
français c'est tout cela que les
français ne veulent plus alors c'est à
vous monsieur le ministre que je demande
de prendre vos responsabilités dans cet
hémicycle devant les représentants des
français annoncée vite la date exacte de
l'examen au sénat du ceta car cela vous
en aurez
[Applaudissements]